if you're looking to land a job in the
cloud there are five career mistakes you
must avoid I'm Lucy and ex AWS Solutions
architect and over the past year I've
mentored over 250 job Seekers through
one-on-one consultations in the process
I've noticed that a lot of people are
making the same mistakes which is why in
this video I want to share with you the
top 5 career mistakes that job Seekers
make when trying to start their Cloud
career the goal of this video is to help
you avoid making these same mistakes so
please give this video a like and save
it for future reference and remember
you're definitely not alone on this
journey if you haven't already make sure
you sign up to our free Tech with Lucy
Cloud community on slack to join a group
of over 3 000 Cloud enthusiasts now the
first career mistake that job Seekers
make is choosing the wrong role to aim
for when you're just starting out you'll
come across roles like Solutions
Architects Cloud engineer Cloud
architect and so on but it's important
to do your own research and not just
space your decision on how well the role
pays or how popular it is make sure you
take some time to understand your own
skills and interests as well towards
your strengths and weaknesses in order
to identify a role that's best for you I
actually made a video last year on why
you shouldn't become an AWS Solutions
architect to clear up some common
misconceptions for example the role of a
Solutions architect at AWS is pretty
customer facing so if you don't enjoy
working with customers you might want to
look into something different there's
actually a fun quiz you can take to
figure out which Cloud role might be
right for you AWS created this recently
and after answering the questions you
get recommended a role as well as some
helpful resources to help you develop
your Cloud skills of course the quiz is
just a bit of fun so please don't use it
to make a final decision but it can help
you start thinking about what rowing
Cloud might align with your preferences
the main point is there are so many
Cloud roles out there so make sure you
do your own research to make an informed
decision once you've decided on the role
you'd like to aim for the next step is
to create a strategy to help you get
there this brings us to mistake number
two not having a clear strategy without
a proper plan in place it can be easy to
get sidetracked and lose sight of your
goals that's why I recommend creating a
road that outlines the exact steps you
need to take to achieve your desired
Cloud role I recently published a video
on how to learn cloud and actually learn
a job where I outline a five-step plan
to guide you along your Cloud Journey
here's an example of what your plan
could look like so in the first month
you could focus on studying I.T
fundamentals second month could be
focused on getting a cloud certification
third month build Cloud projects and
gain hands-on experience and in the
fourth month prepare for interviews and
apply to jobs this is just a general
outline and you'll want to tailor your
plan based on your specific goals and
needs I'd also recommend taking this a
step further by planning out exactly
what you're going to be studying make
sure you block out dedicated time each
week to focus on learning and building
by having a clear plan and actively
working towards your goals you'll be in
a much better place to land a cloud role
this year the third Cloud career mistake
is lost spending enough time building
Hands-On skills so while it's important
to have a strong understanding of the
theoretical Concepts it's just as
important to gain Hands-On practical
experience that you can actually
showcase on your resume and during an
interview here are two ways you can
build your Hands-On Cloud skills so the
first one is by working on a personal
project for example you could build a
serverless e-commerce platform using AWS
or Azure the second way is to take an
online course or workshop and there are
online courses out there that focus on a
specific role or area of Technology
trying to land a job in Tech can be
pretty overwhelming but there are some
platforms out there that make it easier
for you I'd like to introduce you to
today's video sponsor create rivers.com
it's an online platform that offers
immersive programs in QA automation
sales engineering tech support and more
even if you don't have any experience or
background in Tech Career risk can help
you learn everything required to land
your first tech job and they recommend
starting off with the basics by
enrolling in this manual QA course so
how it works is you attend live classes
receive one-on-one guidance from a
personal mentor and get real-world
experience through a remote internship
their students also get access to a
simplified job search system and you can
read about some of their experiences
through the website so if you'd like to
check out their programs I've included a
link in the description below for a 10
discount off any course thank you
careervis.com for sponsoring today's
video now let's get into career mistake
number four which is underestimating the
importance of soft skills given the
current job market having technical
skills by itself is often not enough
developing soft skills like
communication collaboration and problem
solving will not only help you succeed
in interviews but also set you up for
long-term Career Success research
conducted by Harvard University has
concluded that 85 of job success comes
from having well-developed soft skills
and people skills and only 15 of job
success actually comes from Technical
and hard skills we all know at this
point that to improve your technical
skills you can take an online course or
get Hands-On with the technology but how
do you improve your soft skills one way
I improve my soft skills is to actively
put myself in uncomfortable situations
that I know will be good for me this
might involve giving a presentation to a
group of people leading a team or even
creating and Publishing YouTube videos
while these types of situations might
seem intimidating they can help you step
out of your comfort zone and help you
develop soft skills like teamwork and
communication the final but most
important career mistake to avoid is
going on this journey alone networking
and meeting new people is a crucial part
to any job search and this is especially
true when you're applying to roles in
the cloud industry it can help you learn
more about new job opportunities and
gain insights into the industry that you
typically fight online so I'd recommend
taking the initiative to attend industry
events join communities and reach out to
people outside your network to build
relationships one tip I have is to try
and make one new connection every week
for example reaching out to people on
LinkedIn who are Cloud Learners or
people working in roles you want to be
in and on the topic of LinkedIn make
sure your profile is always up to date
with your latest skills and experiences
you could also create a personal website
to share thoughts or document any
projects you've built the reason I say
this is because sometimes hiring
managers and recruiters actually look
online for candidates and when they do
having a strong digital presence will
really help you out okay so those are
the top five Cloud career mistakes I've
seen job Seekers make if there's any I
missed please comment them down below so
that others can avoid them and if you
found this video helpful make sure you
check out this video where I talk about
how to learn cloud computing in order to
actually land a job